bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
une heure pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et la première partie
de cette édition sera consacrée au
mariage pour tous à trois jours de la
manifestation contre le projet de loi
paris débat à suivre ce soir avec armel
le bras chopard maire adjointe
socialiste de guyancourt la féministe
revendiquer notamment en charge d'une
mission pour l'égalité des chances
femmes hommes dans l'enseignement
supérieur favorable vous l'avez été au
mariage pour tous mathieu colombani
coordinateur de la manif pour tous sur
le secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
élégant et légalement pardon a délégué
général du parti chrétien démocrate de
christine boutin opposé à l'idée d'une
union par le mariage de personnes du
même sexe germandrée président dom au
festi associations gays et lesbiennes
fondée en 2002 et françois-xavier
bellamy maire adjoint sans étiquette de
versailles vous avez signé début
décembre une tribune mariage pour tous
justice nulle part publié dans
libération c'était donc en décembre
bonsoir à tous les quatre avant
d'écouter vos arguments respectifs voici
déjà les titres de ce 10 janvier les
titres en images les sujets qui seront
développés dans cette édition les
clients sont attentifs aux prix une
autre catégorie a aussi l'oeil sur les
prix ce sont les agents de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations
il mène des contrôles nous en avons
suivi 1 ce matin un lancement officiel
de l'opération pièces jaunes depuis le
centre hospitalier de versailles et du
monde pour accueillir la présidente de
la fondation bernadette chirac
accompagné de deux parrains christian
karembeu et clément lefert mme récent
médaillé olympique
à quelques jours de la manifestation
parisienne contre le mariage pour tous
les associations se mobilisent pour
faire connaître leur cause un collectif
s'est créé dans les yvelines
nous avons rencontré certains de ses
membres lors d'un tractage devant la
gare de trappes et parallèlement à ce
débat autour du mariage gay la rédaction
vous propose le témoignage de patricia
son ancienne compagne apporter leurs
deux enfants aujourd'hui séparé les deux
femmes se livrent une bataille juridique
patricia n'a pas d'existence légale aux
yeux de ses enfants elle espère que la
loi lui offrira un statut
offrira un statut également beaucoup
deuxième conte choix la manif pour tous
se déroulera le 13 janvier il pourrait
peut-être jusqu'à 300 mille voire plus
dans les rues parisiennes pourquoi se
pose-t-il au mariage pour tous quels
sont les arguments des pro mariage
homosexuel c'est ce que nous allons voir
au cours de la prochaine demi heure et
pour débuter une première question qui
va s'adresser aux anti mariage pour tous
aux organisateurs de cette manif pour
tous nous en avons deux représentants
sur ce plateau en tout cas dans jusqu'à
jusqu'à hier il était encore question de
la procréation médicalement assistée
les députés socialistes ont dit qu'ils
ne déposeraient pas d'amendement
finalement pour aller en ce sens ça veut
dire qu'il sera plus difficile de
mobiliser la pma concentrait beaucoup de
critiques étaient un petit peu là
l'argument principal également pour vous
il y à là je pense une posture de
communication qui est qui est très
claire et d'ailleurs j'en ai changé et
pas plus tard que cet après midi et en
début d'après midi avec un parlementaire
socialiste qui vous disaient très bien
que l'amendement était conservée mais
sera déposée dans le deuxième texte
concernant la famille qui devrait
arriver au printemps donc ça te trouve
bien que l'amendement aux pma est
conservé mais là en tout cas on est sur
une mobilisation contre le mariage pour
tous y avait cet argument là de la pma
ça ne remet pas en cause la mobilisation
ça ne permet pas en cause la
mobilisation et je le répète le texte du
gouvernement sur le mariage pour tous
sera suivi d'un deuxième texte sur la
famille c'est un package et dans ce
deuxième texte qu'il y aura l'amendement
pma donc ça ne change rien en ce qui
vous concerne le retrait pour l'instant
de la pma pour parler de ce sujet que
les députés socialistes finalement ne
dépose pas d'amendement oui mais il sera
effectivement il y arrivera à
l'assemblée plus tard dans le texte qui
sera voté sur la sur la famille
donc ça ne sera finalement rien enfin
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné
effectivement il ya eu 1
une incompréhension de la part donc des
français c'est pour ça qu'il ya un recul
clairement du gouvernement l'idée c'est
effectivement de dire qu' il y a le
mariage pour tous donc où effectivement
les couples homosexuels pourront comme
le prévoient les frontons égalité
fraternité il est dit et c'est aussi
l'égalité des droits et en l'occurrence
on n'est pas des sous citoyens
les homosexuels sont pas donc forcément
des sous citoyens et c'est vrai que pour
le coup il y avait donc le mariage pour
tous il y avait donc l'adoption il ya
aussi donc la pma et c'est vrai que pour
le coup les français étaient quand même
très hostile donc à la pma et il
paraissait plus judicieux que ce soit
donc déporté sur les textes concernant
donc tout ce qui va être donc famille ce
sera en mars et alors que le projet de
loi sur le mariage pointu sera présenté
d'ici la fin du mois de janvier nous
avons deux représentants qui défendent
ce mariage pour tous nous avons deux
représentants de la manif pour tous sur
ce plateau avant de continuer j'aimerais
que chacun nous donne un petit peu ce
ses arguments pourquoi êtes-vous
favorable déjà tout d'abord à ce mariage
pour tous vous venez de le dire c'est
une simple question d'égalité
les citoyens doivent tous avoir les
mêmes droits
y'a pas des sous citoyens qui seraient
victimes de discrimination c'est le
premier élément du côté de ceux qui
veulent se marier
maintenant je connais l'argument on va
nous parler les savait répondre après
c'est déjà c'est le le même le deuxième
le deuxième quoi la question des enfants
je rappelle que tous ceux qui se marient
et qu'ils sont hétérosexuels ne sont pas
obligé de proclamer avant le mariage
qu'ils vont avoir ou qu'ils désirent
avoir des enfants mais ceux qui veulent
avoir des enfants et quand il ya des
enfants puisque à des couples
actuellement homosexuels non mariés
voilà
et bien à ce moment là c'est l'intérêt
des enfants qu'il faut considérer
l'intérêt des enfants d'avoir un foyer
et un foyer avec de l'affection et une
éducation qui leur est possible
françois-xavier bel ami nous a pas
encore entendu je crois qu'au fond ce
qui est en jeu on parlait tout à l'heure
la question de la pma c'est un choix un
choix très important et de ce pont du
las je crois que là encore toutes les
parties dans ce débat sont d'accord pour
reconnaître l'importance de cette
décision que nous avons à prendre cette
décision je veux great là encore pour
reparler de la pma qu'on en tronquant
quelque sorte les conséquences je crois
qu'on a un choix à faire qui impliquent
un certain nombre de conséquences
et si nous choisissons de débattre
autour d'une égalité effective de tous
les couples dans le rapport au mariage
et dans le rapport à l'enfantement dans
le rapport à la possibilité d'avoir des
enfants et de les élever alors dans ce
cas il faut bien mesurer les
conséquences de notre choix cela
signifie qu'il faudra nécessairement
seulement adopté le mariage pour tous
mais aussi adopter vous l'avais dit la
procréation médicalement assistée
l'adoption sera largement insuffisante
pour que tous les couples puissent
recevoir des enfants et donc adopté la
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les couples de lesbiennes et la
gestation pour autrui pour les couples
gays c'est une la médiacité vous a
laissé par les jeux voyagiste pouvoir
terminer mon propos je vois que on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas sans incohérence
ne pas admettre cette nécessité absolue
de ces deux dispositifs à limite on a le
droit de militer pour ces dispositifs je
ne me reproche à personne de le faire
mais je crois qu'il faut bien
reconnaître la nature des conséquences
que nous avons à regarder avec vraiment
beaucoup de discernement
je crois en moi pour ma part en fait
qu'en réalité c'est une fausse idée de
l'égalité qu'il s'agit moi je suis
attaché comme tout le monde à ce que la
justice soit rendue à chacun et je crois
que c'est très important que nous nous
engagions ensemble vous êtes élu nous
sommes plusieurs ici à être élus autour
de cette table pour que la justice soit
garanti à tous et en particulier pour
que les discriminations qui peuvent
encore peser sur les personnes
homosexuelles 16 parce qu'elles sont
insupportables dans notre société
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
la discrimination concerne les personnes
voient ce qu'elles concernent des
couples
de fait je crois que la nature de
l'amour homosexuel et la nature de
l'amour hétérosexuel ne sont pas
exactement la même
ça ne signifie pas qu'il y ait une
dignité inférieur bien sûr aimer un
homme quand on est jeune homme ou d'une
femme ce n'est pas la même chose vous
êtes féminine
je crois qu'il faut reconnaître la 5
germandrée j'aimerais votre réaction
parce que ça vous a fait bondir non mais
à un moment donné il faut pas tout
mélanger on va éviter de prendre des
raccourcis un moment même c'est bien con
si on y viendra forcément un jour je
crois qu'il faut vraiment présenter la
poste tel quel c'est à dire que dire
qu'il n'ya pas d'égalité entre un amour
hétérosexuels un amour homosexuel je
suis désolé j'avais l'égalité j'ai dit
qu'il n'y avait pas d' identité entre
les deux et la culture antique fera si
nécessaire mais le brunch au parc c'est
à dire de parler d' amalgame aussi sur
la gpa
elle est interdite actuellement aux
couples hétérosexuels donc s'il ya
égalité y aura égalité pour tous une
passion domination entre les couples
homosexuels et les couples homosexuels
femme par définition ne m'attendais à
raison ce ce débat d'ailleurs
visiblement donc peut pas être mélangés
au mariage pour tous parce que ça crée
un amalgame c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
ça a été ça a été retiré ces jours ci
enfin vous disiez juste un instant tous
les deux vous étiez d'accord pour dire
que le l'amendement pma n'était pas
retiré mais qu'ils étaient juste des
prêts ne rentrent pas dans le cadre d'un
mariage blanc
ça vous intéresse ce soir c'est le texte
et maria seront prises pour enregistrer
et encore une fois c'est la posture du
libyen toujours vu les flammes un joli
de prendre des postures avec qui qui
sont pas corrects on réentend en réalité
on a le mariage pour tous avec
effectivement c'est pour ses contres etc
on vous dit que la pma ce sera pour plus
tard parce qu'effectivement c'est
peut-être pas les mêmes enjeux et c'est
le mais c'est pas le même délai non
c'est pas le même jeu sera de le re
d'oise est différent et on sera sûr de
donner le tournis emblématique c'est
reviendra théâtre sur cette question là
c'est d'une hypocrisie flagrante mais
non mais non merci et enfin mais si
regardez bien la regardons bien la
poésie face à la majorité non
réglementaire actuel ce n'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est christiane taubira la
question de l'homoparentalité et de tout
ce qui
va avec c'est à dire le mariage
l'adoption et la reconnaissance de
désorientation sexuelle
c'est un choix de civilisation c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est christiane taubira
garde des sceaux vous descendez la rando
familiale et fortis par deux moines neuf
acteurs pour ce que nous demandons le
référendum
donc nous n'avons pas peur nous faisons
confiance aux français et les français
seront en sagesse et en discernement
engager la france dans ce choix de
problèmes de tous a élu aujourd'hui on
est en démocratie mal en pis le vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dès ma vie effectivement
un débat qui qui souhaitent être créés
entre autres par christine boutin
puisqu'elle le réclame le souci de ce
débat c'est que le pacs a mis un an un
an avec des tas de débats sans qui on
était quand même très controversée où il
ya eu effectivement des montées en
puissance d'homophobie on n'est même pas
à zéro heure de débat parce
qu'effectivement ces sorties au moment
où françois hollande donc l'avait mis
dans cet axe vers les urgences devons
entendre dire que pour le moment on est
à 0 heure de débat je suis ravi non mais
bien de requins mais je dois maintenant
mais c'est vrai faux
nous sommes d'accord il faut lien mois
de débat actuellement le fraysse
audience a fait les dernières ont eu
lieu en amont et les basses abbas a fait
devant la commission des lois sur le
mariage en messieurs s'il n'y a pas de
débat que l'on pense que je suis à la
fois que vous l'avez évoqué mon frère
fred au times sur le karabakh comme elle
est un sacré aussi une montée en
puissance de l'homophobie
ça crée des tensions essais et c'est
aussi ça qu'on dénonce aujourd'hui
alors les amis j'ai gravi laquelle sont
du référendum pour le mot vous souhaitez
un macaron d'hommes aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous souhaitez également un
référendum que ce soit a tranché ce qui
moi je sais pas si ça doit passer par la
voie référendaire parce que en effet je
fais confiance au parlement pour statuer
je crois simplement qu'on a vécue par
exemple dans dans les dernières années
un moment exemplaire de démocratie
participative puisque c'est de cela
qu'il s'agit et qu'ils étaient par
exemple les états généraux de la
bioéthique se dira peut-être que c'est à
la fin au parlement de statut et il a
été élu pour ça et en effet il se
présente avec un mandat mais ce serait
tout à l'honneur du gouvernement
socialiste et de la majorité socialiste
de venir devant les français et de leur
dire nous avons été élus pour prendre
cette décision et nous nous engageons à
la tenir maintenant nous voudrions
prendre le temps de discuter vraiment
avec vous de tout ce que cela implique
et c'est pour ça que je regrette ce
séquençage de renforcer son parlement a
nécessairement référent dans un conte
qu'elle joue le sort de table
il ya eu des débats ont eu lieu d'une
façon hebdomadaire devant la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale
ils ont largement eu lieu dans les
médias et un dossier qui est haut comme
ça le breton j'ai juste une petite leçon
de cette question référendum faut-il un
référendum ou non certains élus
notamment à gauche aussi se sont
prononcés pour jean philippe mallet
député de la 11e circonscription
socialiste a appelé à un référendum
notamment
je vous propose cette semi cros trottoir
que nous avons réalisé aujourd'hui c'est
vous qui avez la parole souhaitez-vous
ou non un référendum non je crois qu'on
est guidé des députés ils doivent
pouvoir résoudre ce problème
si on ne fait un référendum à chaque
fois qu'on se pose une question je ne
vois pas la communion ouais pourquoi pas
moi non
c'est ridicule un référendum pourquoi
alors là il faut il faut juste je sais
pas pouvoir en parler un petit peu
calmement sens on est sans compter tout
l'effectif parce que vous
on arrive à des vers et qui sera un
petit peu quand même auxerre ya d'autres
choses à s'occuper en ce moment que ce
problème je crois non non ce genre de
sujet et c'est pour ça qu'on les ait dit
qu'on élit les politiques c'est pour
qu'ils prennent des décisions
importantes et que c'est très bien que
ça soit pas parmi les quatre invités qui
sont sur le plateau ce soir nous en
avons 3 qui siège dans différents
conseils municipaux que ce soit à
versailles à montigny le bretonneux ou à
guyancourt est ce qu'au sein de vos
différents conseils municipaux les
discussions ont lieu aussi sur ces
questions là par exemple si la loi est
votée est ce que oui ou non le maire
célébrera et ses adjoints ces différents
mariages homosexuels
c'est une évidence si la loi ça par
ailleurs si elles veulent pas certains
maires se sont prononcés contre célèbres
amants se soumettre à la loi si les
maires ne se soumettent plus à la loi où
va-t-on on savait maîtriser un cra si la
position du conseil municipal de
montigny sur cette question comme sur
d'autres consiste à dire que les élus de
montigny sont là pour gérer les affaires
locales de la ville de montigny et que
les débats nationaux ne sont pas à
s'ingérer dans la municipalité
c'est à dire que si la loi passe en
conseil municipal de vente signés on
respectera la loi sinon ça ne veut pas
dire ça du tout alors ça veut juste dire
que la municipale le conseil municipal
de montigny considère qu' il y à des
parlementaires ou le président de la
république
dans le cas d'un référendum pour
trancher ces questions là le conseil
municipal de montigné n'a pas en tant
que tel mais là on est sur l'impact à se
mêler d'une arme cachée du ballet débat
qui précède l'adoption de la loi
française fixe interne et ben on se sent
ce si elle est adoptée ce qui n'est pas
encore sûr nous avons déjà vu internet
ici nous avons déjà vu des lois adoptées
qui n'ont jamais été appliquées c'est
des choses qui existent
je vous rappelle le l'exemple du cpe ou
de l'école libre qu avait été adoptée
aussi donc
en ce sens en ce sens et en le maire est
responsable de l'état civil de sa
commune et chaque élu municipal est
libre de faire le mariage tout comme il
est libre aujourd'hui de faire ou non un
mariage
je viens de dire sur quoi si demain vous
avez un couple homosexuel qui vient vous
voir si la loi est adoptée
vous ferez vous ferez genou célèbrerai
pas ce mariage d'accord donc vous serez
contre effectivement bien entendu sur ce
plateau pour justement et je ne suis pas
mère de ma commune donc je n'ai pas
obligation légale de célébrer quelques
mariages que ce soit donc je ne
célèbrerai pas sous ces voyages ce qui
vous concerne
pour versailles les orateurs ont été
bien sûr à la solution a été très très
très vive très approfondie et de ce
point de vue là je crois que nous avons
tous aussi collectivement regretté que
je crois que les élus locaux n'aient pas
été assez consulté vous dites il ya eu
un débat mais en réalité le débat a
commencé la loi était déjà écrite et pas
une seule virgule n'a été changé après
les consultations
je voulais simplement dire que je crois
que malheureusement il aurait été
opportun que les élus locaux que les
maires de toutes tendances de toutes
couleurs soient consultés sur cette
question là ils ne l'ont pas été nous
avons voté nous pour nous une motion en
conseil municipal qui a recueilli une
très large majorité une quasi unanimité
tous les groupes politique l'ont votée
il ya eu que deux abstentions sur les 53
membres que compte le conseil municipal
pour dire précisément que nous pensions
qu'il y avait là une question très
importante et qu'elle méritait un débat
approfondi
en réalité le débat ça fait 12 ans qu'on
l'a avec le pacs et même bien avant
parce que le débat sur le pacs était
plus d'un an donc ça fait presque 14 ans
qu'on en parle les couples homosexuels
ont toujours réclamer l'égalité
d'ailleurs ça vous a pas échappé ça
s'appelle le mariage pour tous il s'agit
pas de faire un mariage gay il s'agit de
faire un mariage pour tout le monde
effectivement on est dans l'égalité et
pour le coup le pacs il y avait des
opposants aux taxes christine boutin en
faisait partie des opposants au pacs moi
je faisais partie de ceux qui
réfléchissait à comment faire en sorte
que les sociétés évoluent grâce à ce
pacte civil donc et face à ce pacs et
c'est vrai que pour le coup aujourd'hui
ça profite aussi et en majeure partie
aux hétérosexuels
donc je serais ravi effectivement que
une fois de plus la communauté
homosexuelle
avancer les choses au profit de
l'ensemble de la population française
comme dans d'autres pays parce que je
rappelle que ce n'est pas une idée
saugrenue françois hollande a le courage
de le mettre en place et il a été élu
pour ça parce que ça fait partie donc de
ces propositions mais effectivement faut
avoir le courage de le faire il y en a
d'autres qui aimeraient le faire y
compris dans la majorité
enfin au sein de l'ump entre haute et en
lait et en l'occurrence c'est vrai que
le pacs et ce à des lacunes et
aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour ça qu'on se
dirige vers le mariage pour tous même
une grande différence c'est que le pacs
a ses défauts mais c'était un dispositif
nouveau le mariage pour tous ne consiste
pas à apporter quelque chose doit
l'avoir depuis des années de mariage
pour tous deux constituent pas apporter
quelque chose de plus ce mariage qui
consiste à avoir depuis des lunes enlevé
quelque chose au mariage quelques jours
le fait que vous en actuellement le
mariage pour tous consiste à enlever du
texte de la loi les mots de père de mère
d'épousé d'épouser autrement dit à
enlever leurs pairs de la différence des
sexes et de ce point de vue là madame je
m'étonne que vous qui êtes féministes
qui défendent et la place des femmes
dans la société vous acceptiez cette
société de l'indifférenciation qui se
dessine à travers elle alors je ne
conteste pas que le mariage pour tous
soit demandée pour des raisons qui sont
tout à fait généreuse est tout à fait
légitime il ya un désir qu'il faut
entendre les foréziens ont tellement
c'est juste une question de mentalité je
veux dire par là que ceux qui embrassent
envers notre réaction des façons le fond
avec une grande générosité mais je crois
qu'il ya une très grande contradiction
entre le fait de vouloir défendre nos
différences et le fait de vouloir les
écraser dans un texte comme celui ci qui
va tout simplement retiré de notre code
civil les termes de père et de mère
d'épousé des pour l'altérité qui est
déterminant les droits sont pas avec la
police
permettez-moi thématique match combattu
pour l'occasion les célèbres colombani
pour résumer c'est réparé puisque vous
blottir à 148 reprises les mots de père
et mère me sape du coach et lui ça vous
rappelez vous marier jeune femme tout va
mais là n'est pas la question qui
taraude sauvé ça retire à la société et
aux enfants sages août non mais on va
revenir sur cette question des mercières
la mémoire a déjà tenté du maire mathieu
colombani je m'étonne à mon tour que
vous ayez ce type de réaction par
rapport aux féministes alors que les
mêmes
on refusait qu'il y ait des cours sur ce
qu'on appelle le genre c'est à dire les
rapports sociaux de sexe entre hommes et
femmes est nouveau ça tout à fait je ne
comprends pas qu'un féministes ou qu'une
féministe défendre la théorie du genre
qui présuppose précisément que le modèle
d'une altérité entre l'homme et la femme
n'existe pas autrement dit la théorie du
genre sur l'île d'ischia ce modèle de
terroir et bio l'écrasement de la série
ne doit pas y avoir de différence et de
hiérarchie et de domination contre
l'inégalité l'alleud le combat du genre
c'est le combat contre la différence et
c'est tout à fait différent précisément
on peut lutter pour l'égalité des sexes
sans lutter nécessairement pour l'heure
homogénéisation douala on imagine bien
une photo je crois que la donne est
toute façon vous considérez le mariage
si j'allais bien le fils naturel de la
théorie du genre c'est normal qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui c'est à dire d'une
idée selon laquelle font naître
l'humanité la théorie du genre expliqué
contre les cours sur la sexualité et
tout d'un coup vous nous rappeler
d'avoir des hommes et des temps revient
à cette question du mariage pour tous et
on parlait du pacs tout à l'heure alors
j'aimerais juste qu'on revienne sur sa
pour ce soit un petit peu plus clair que
ce qui l'est ce qui pourrait changer
avec l'adoption de ce projet de loi du
mariage pour tous ce qu'est ce qu'ils
figurent également actuellement dans le
pacs nous sommes allés poser la question
à une avocate qui est spécialisé dans le
droit des familles voici ses
explications le baxo n'entraîne pas de
liens personnels véritable entre les
personnes pacsées par exemple
il n'y a pas la possibilité de porter le
nom de son compagnon
on n'a pas
lorsqu'il ya une rupture de fax et bien
il est possible
que l'ancien pacsés épouser la fille de
son ancienne compagne
ce qui ne crée pas de liens familiaux
véritable ensuite sur un plan
patrimonial et bien
au niveau du droit des successions les
pacsés n'ont pas tout à fait moi de là
même là les mêmes avantages au niveau de
l'héritage
ils ne sont pas héritier de leurs de
l'heure
le conjoint il
ne peuvent prétendre à il part de
l'héritage que dans la mesure il y à un
testament en leur faveur
ils ne peuvent prétendre ils ne peuvent
pas prétendre non plus à la pension de
réversion de l'heure
compagnes ou compagnons prédécédé voilà
il ya un certain nombre de différences
qui effectivement sont tout à fait
importante
le mariage pour tous
c'est effectivement eu
la réunion de deux personnes parce que
le pacs s'avère tout à fait insuffisant
pour donner satisfaction aux couples
homosexuels
donc le mariage pour tous pourquoi pas
simplement il va falloir réfléchir à un
certain nombre de conséquences que ça va
poser sur le plan de l'organisation de
la société mariage pour tous alors le
mariage déjà c
c'est organisé autour de la fin c'est
pour encadrer la
la filiation notamment l'une des
conséquences du mariage c'est de ces
deux d'instaurer une présomption de
paternité au profit du conjoint
c'est à dire que un enfant né dans le
mariage a pour père le mari cette
présomption de paternité pose un
véritable problème s'agissant de couples
homosexuels puisque la question qui se
pose c'est est ce qu'on va là réservé
uniquement aux couples hétérosexuels
est ce que on va la supprimer purement
et simplement après tout pourquoi pas ni
à réfléchit déjà à plusieurs reprises
parce que pourquoi une présomption de
paternité bon on peut éventuellement
envisager la supprimer purement et
simplement
ou bien est-ce qu'on va l'étendre à tous
les couples
c'est la solution d'ailleurs qui a été
retenue par le canada voilà ça pour ces
quelques points soulevés par cette
avocate qui nous a précisé tout même les
grandes différences avec le pacs et puis
le mariage donc véritablement
aujourd'hui germandrée par exemple le
pacs ça ne répond pas aux besoins et aux
attentes en tout cas de la communauté
homosexuelle
en tous les cas quand on a créé le pacs
et qu'on a tous réfléchir entre des
parlementaires des associatifs et autres
à monter le pacs effectivement on n'a
pas vu qu'il y avait des autant de
lacunes à l'époque parce qu'il fallait
bien le tester et aujourd'hui le pacs
est un franc succès je rappelle quand
même au petit passage que la courbe du
pacs d'ici un an ou deux ans dépassera
celle du mariage
et effectivement il ya aujourd'hui
beaucoup de couples hétérosexuels qui se
servent du pacs le pacs a été une vraie
avancée il ya des lacunes et pour
combler ces lacunes
il faut effectivement avoir le mariage
pour tous monsieur colombani le pacs
pour vous c'est une évolution déjà
suffisante ça répondait à un moment
donné à des besoins
ensuite on ne peut pas dire que le pacs
soit une revendication ce le fut à
l'époque je parle aujourd'hui
la communauté même si je n'aime pas ce
terme parce qu'on vit dans un pays on
veut pas rentrer communauté des
homosexuels
il y à il ya eu en 2010 9000 pacs entre
homosexuels 9000 ce qui représente au 6%
la totalité de des pacs on est bien
d'accord il ya bien plus de 18000
homosexuels en france cela veut donc
dire qu'il n'ya pas la demande de la
part des homosexuels vivant en couple ou
non d'avoir ce pacs il ya peut-être une
avancée pour le mariage p 500 des
questions comme par exemple sur les
héritiers sur les pensions de revers
mais sur les héritiers les états sur les
héritiers une avocate spécialiste du
droit de la famille que nous venons
d'entendre l'a très bien dit il y a le
testament et sa réponse mais lorsque
vous vous pacser vous savez alors franck
béria se produisent lorsque vous savez
lorsque vous vous vous pacser vous savez
qu'en cas de décès vous aurez besoin
d'un testament et bien fait écrivez
rédigé le testament
non mais marié laurencin dans leur évite
ces dix fois plus simple de se marier
ils savent où se retirera rien enfin
honnêtement on ajoute on enlève pas vous
pouvez pas être contre ça la liberté
égalité fraternité
c'est ce que tous les élus fin vous êtes
trois élus ici je pense que vous êtes
tous capables effectivement d'adhérer à
ce concept d'égalité et on les en
l'occurrence le mariage pour tous c'est
l'égalité pour tous la manif pour tous
et la division pour toute là dessus
l'égalité de dignité nous sommes tous
d'accord là dessus
venez à l'antenne lorsque l'ours nouveau
nuage sous silence rien lorsque je marie
et lorsque nous marions et madame vous
le savez très bien où tout au tournoi
lorsque nous lisons les articles 212 et
compagnie du code civil notamment
l'article 214 qui prévoit la
contribution des époux aux charges du
mariage
la raison pour laquelle cette technique
cet article est lui au mariage
c'est aussi pour l'après en cas de
séparation
et vous savez très bien que un mariage
français n'est jamais totalement dissous
puisque on organise la succession des
biens et en organise autour de l'enfant
un socle solide et encadrée et donc ce
qui prouve bien et madame l'a très bien
dit et ce n'est pas le mois qu'ils
disent
le doyen carbonnier que l'un des plus
grands 6 analystes français la question
du mariage c'est la question de la
filiation donc de l'enfant et donc
l'intérêt est alors donc l'intérêt
supérieur
vous n'êtes vous pas qu'on a raison mais
tout va bien m'aider pour le mariage je
crois on peut on peut être pour ou
contre le mariage pour tous mais il faut
quand même qu'on s'accorde sur un point
si non on ne peut pas en parler
sérieusement c'est que ça n'est pas une
réforme anodine ça n'est pas une banale
si on ne peut pas dire que ça ne change
rien et je crois de ce produit là pour
revenir au point que nous évoquions tout
à l'heure que la disparition de
l'altérité du père et de la mère de
l'époux ou de l'épousé constitue de fait
une sorte de changement total de paradis
un mariage tout à l'heure l'avocate que
nous entendions me disait le mariage a
été construit pour accompagner pour
structurer la filiation et la filiation
qu'est ce que c'est c'est tout
simplement pour accompagner le la
fécondité de lui un mariage sur deux en
ile-de-france divorce et je vous propose
experts des vous avez des doutes à deux
familles monoparentales et vous avez des
tas de familles reconstituées où est le
problème
oui j'aimerais justement qu'on écoute un
témoignage vous pourrez ensuite réagir
et poursuivre la discussion ce
témoignage est une situation très
concrète celle de patricia son ancienne
compagne apporter leurs deux enfants
aujourd'hui elles sont séparés les deux
femmes se livrent une bataille juridique
patricia n'a pas d'existence légale aux
yeux de ses enfants espère que la loi va
lui offrir un statut aux frères en tout
cas un statut à ceux qui seraient
confrontés par la suite à cette
situation
voici ce témoignage recueilli par
catherine gelato et patrick jacques de
dixmude patricia vécu treize ans avec
une femme
au bout de cinq ans de vie commune elles
ont fait le choix d'enfants portés par
sa compagne patricia qui témoignent à
visage couvert à tous suivi les rendez
vous avec les médecins les psychologues
le gynécologue les inséminations en
belgique jusqu'à l'accouchement de leur
histoire de vie sont nées deux filles
âgées aujourd'hui de trois ans et demi
et 7 ans
depuis janvier 2011 patricia est séparée
et aux yeux de la loi elle n'a pas
d'existence légale alors au départ on
voulait faire une charte
et puis cette charte la faire valider
devant un juge
après avec la vie courante on l'a pas
fait on a été consulté un avocat pour
faire une délégation d'autorité
parentale partiel on a commencé et puis
on a arrêté on a arrêté en cours de
route parce qu'à versailles c'était
c'était des refus catégoriques au
tribunal donc on n'avait rien fait au
moment de la séparation et on s'était
toujours dit que s'il y avait séparation
on ferait une garde alternée ou on
s'arrangerait pour faire une garde pour
que
pour que j'aie les enfants c'est ce qui
s'est fait au début au bout de six mois
la changer d'avis on a fait un week-end
sur deux et puis le mardi soir
et au bout de six mois encore elle a
changé d'avis et là elle m'a dit tu les
verras une heure par semaine
tu n'as aucun droit tu n'es rien tu les
verras une heure par semaine le dimanche
quand ça m'arrange ses deux filles ne
sont plus venus dans la maison d'orgeval
depuis le mois de juillet dernier dans
leur chambre
rien n'a bougé comme un temps suspendue
à la douleur ici c'est la chambre de la
grande c'est la chambre qu'elle avait
quand elle était toute petite
il ya tous les doudous de cantal et
quand elle est née mais c'est vrai que
temps en temps je rentre dans la chambre
dans les placards ya les vêtements
il ya tous les tous les jouets et
et je me suis effondrée plusieurs points
ce qui la fait tenir la procédure
juridique qu'elle a lancée pour obtenir
un droit de visite et d'hébergement
une première audience a eu lieu le 3
décembre le magistrat doit rendre son
avis le 21 janvier
patricia espère que le mariage pour tous
s'il est adopté
prévoir à l'autorité parentale délégués
ou conjointe
le vrai débat c'est pas le mariage d
c'est pas que le mariage c'est les
enfants et tout le monde le sait que
c'est le vrai débat c'est l'adoption des
enfants
je pense que on est très en retard par
rapport à d'autres pays
quand je vois la hollande où c'est
commun chez eux et depuis quelques
années
le l'espagne où ils ont admis l'adoption
alors que l'espagne est un pays latin
pays latins et catholique et que je vois
le retard qu'a la france
je trouve pas qu'on feint vision
positive est difficile à avoir
voilà pour ce témoignage aimerait votre
réaction on sent une vraie d'être une
vraie détresse
il manque quelque chose actuellement
est-ce qu éventuellement ce mariage pour
tous ne permettra de ne permettrait pas
d'éviter ce genre de détresse
effectivement il y à la détresse humaine
dans ce reportage et quand je voyais mon
interlocuteur sourire et rigoler gt gt
gt vous attendez à rien dévoiler ses
réponses jérôme andré parce que on va
quand même essayer raconte j'ai
rencontré beaucoup vont générer chez lui
même ils sont passés au rouge est
lamentable et cette situation elle
n'aurait pas lieu si la france avait
pris ses responsabilités au moment du
pacs et si effectivement au lieu de
créer un pacs tous les associatifs on
avait demandé un le mariage on en serait
juste pas là et cette situation allait
juste dramatique et on a ici en
l'occurrence des élus il ya beaucoup
d'élus il ya beaucoup de parlementaires
qui ferait bien de regarder ce style de
reportage parce que ça en l'occurrence
ça c'est la vraie vie dans la mecque des
vrais gens et des vrais gens qui
souffrent mais je vois qu'il match à
colombes aller alors ce combat ni je
vous rende la parole parce que je vous
interromps plus pour que je demanderai
puisse répondre sur ce point précis là
je redis que j'ai choqué que certaines
personnes rigole autour de ce plateau en
regardant ce reportage la réplique et
deuxièmement deuxièmement il y as we une
vraie détresse toutefois ce reportage a
le mérite de remettre l'enfant et
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant au coeur
du débat est donc de s'interroger sur la
place et dans quel cadre nous souhaitons
élever les enfants en france donc
qu'alain quel est l'intérêt à patricia
concret on a enterré dans l'intérieur et
de l'enfant est bien la question
je voulais simplement dire qu'il ya il
ya quand même un autrement que dans
cette histoire qu'on vient de voir et
qui effectivement qui effectivement
tragique
un manque qui n'apparaît pas du tout et
de ce point de vue là il ya une
expression peut-être un peu contestable
dans la façon dont il dans l'histoire
nous est raconté on nous dit de
l'histoire de ces deux femmes sont nés
deux enfants
cette expression excusez moi elle est
inexact ses enfants de son panier d'une
histoire entre deux femmes ces enfants
elles sont nées de l'union
nécessairement de l'union d'un homme et
d'une femme
un projet commun de 2 vers leur camp
mais c'est d'abord de dire quand même
d'accord mais mathieu il ya quand même
un manque il ya quand même un manque
dans cette histoire que je voulais
souligner c'est que ses deux filles
manquent d'un père et que nulle part il
ne parlait de leur père
autrement dit elles ont ils accompagnent
ils ont décidé d'avancer les enfants
ensemble
aujourd'hui ces deux femmes se sont
séparés ça arrive dans le monde et que
de frapper alors c'est juste compliqué
c'est que l'on parle en même temps et
tout le monde parle plus fort là je
réponds de vos expressions une structure
ancestrales laissons nos ancêtres dormir
là où ils sont la famille a évolué il ya
des familles recomposées qui ont deux
papas de maman et on est en train
d'essayer de voir comment on pourra
donner des droits aux beaux parents il
ya des familles monoparentales
il ya vous avez exactement la même
attitude comme vous l'avez eue par
rapport au pacs comme vous l'avez eue à
une époque par rapport à l ivg
comme vous l'avez eue à une époque
encore plus vous allez bien vous avez
bien compris le débat vous le répète
tous en même temps ce n'est pas
compréhensible et donc ça ne sert à rien
allez-y l'un après l'autre ce serait
mieux
j'aimerais bien juste te dire malgré
tout qui en fait il y à une question
profonde qui est posée c'est de cette
question dont il faut prendre la mesure
est ce que le fait de naître d'un père
et d'une mère est un fait culturel ou
est ce que c'est un fait de nature est
ce que le besoin que nous avons de nos
origines est un fait culturel ou est ce
que c'est un fait de nature de ce
sanglant vous me répondrez que les
configurations familiales sont
extrêmement diverses et c'est vrai et il
est nécessaire que la loi accompagne la
différence de ces configurations
familiales et qu'elle garantisse les
droits de chacun au mieux malgré tout je
crois que la loi est faite pour fixer
des repères pour fixer des normes et
pour dire ce qui est bon ce qui est même
lorsqu'il s'agit d'enfants le meilleur
pas simplement pour dire tout ce qui
peut se produire pour accompagner tout
ce qui peut se produire parce que dans
ce cas là vous voyez on pourrait aussi
partir du fait que un enfant pourrait
grandir dans n'importe quelle situation
il n'est pas condamné aux malheurs
wietpas condamné à être malheureux un
enfant qui a perdu son père ou sa mère
n'est pas condamné mais là en
l'occurrence sur mathis oiseau très
stressé ce masque la situation
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît 6 1 6 2
les femmes ou deux hommes s'il vous
plaît j'aimerais juste jusqu'à vous
puissiez répondre à cette question très
précisément pour cette femme qu'on a vu
dans ce témoignage d'une situation de
détresse de la part de cette femme qui
ne voit plus les deux enfants qu'elle
avait décidé d'avoir avec sa compagne à
l'époque il ya forcément une souffrance
aussi de la part des deux enfants qui ne
voient plus non plus leur deuxième maman
quelle réponse on peut leur apporter il
d'abord un deuxième moment ça n'existe
pas
en l'occurrence jacques asselin qui va
s'exercer
aucun enfant né de deux mamans toute
personne toute personne et mais les deux
fonds ont été levés par deux mamans
on estime à 4000 dany boon attendez vous
pouvez par exemple vous pouvez pas peut
pas dire à côté
il ne faut pas et c'est là toute la
différence et le coeur du débat
est ce que comme le disait monsieur
bellamy à l'instant c'est un fait
culturel ou un fait de nature ça
n'existe pas aucune personne humaine
n'est au monde de la rencontre de deux
gamètes féministes ou de 2 km est
masculine deux enfants s'installent
veille marc green var et c'est ma
question l'une des réponses l'une des
réponses sur l'une des réponses ci est
monsieur bel ami l'a très bien dit
encore une fois c'est la question du
père on ne parle pas du père de ses
enfants dans ce reportage est l'une des
réponses apportées à cette dame comme
aux enfants c'est que le père soit
présent et qu'on laisse le met la
pression et les habiletés mais on gagne
c'est dans cette optique la bienvenue on
n'est pas sur scène il ya des jours n'a
rien à couche il ya des femmes qui
accouchent et qui n'ont juste pas de
mari et ça donne des familles
monoparentales
bienvenue en france on peut avoir il ya
aussi des gens qui adoptent et qui sont
justes tout seul il ya aussi des pères
qui peuvent être décédé enfin un moment
donné ah oui françois xavier bellamy
juste mais c'est pierre répond jérôme
andré si vous avez terminé
je vous passe la parole à l'eysée voilà
l'un après l'autre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue en 2013 aussi à 2013 il y a
des enfants qui sont nés d'une
procréation médicalement assistée d'une
mère célibataire ou d'une mère qui était
en couple avec une autre femme et qui
arrivés à l'âge adulte ou même avant
l'âge adulte se pose de façon spontanée
et naturelle on ne peut pas dire que ce
soit un fait de culture
la question de leur origine et la
question de l'anonymat par exemple de du
donneur de sperme
c'est une question profonde c'est une
question vous ne pouvez pas la négliger
cette douleur là cette douleur là mais
sculptée dans la dernière l'autre base
c'est une question fondamentale le 7-8
va devoir s'achever juste un dernier
micro trottoir pour ou contre le mariage
homosexuel c'est vous qui aurez le mot
de la fin est revenu à saint quentinois
prononcez vous on vous écoute son micro
trottoir je suis plutôt pour nous parce
que je pense effectivement que tout dans
la droite de se marier il n'y a pas de
différence entre les uns et les autres
que voilà donc il faut être tolérant et
accueillant contre parce que l enfant a
besoin d'un père une merde je suis
contre parce que je pense que derrière
va se poser la question des enfants et
c'est surtout pour les enfants que je
suis content pour le mariage
oui mais pour l'adoption je suis content
à cause d'eux le mariage en lui-même je
pense que le pacs peut suffire je sais
tu bout pourquoi parce que tout le monde
doit avoir les mêmes droits
y'a pas avoir des différences rapport
une sexualité différente et puis le
pense que le droit de l'enfant il est
respecté de tous ces cas puisqu'il ya
bien un plein de familles monoparentales
et le débat qui se poursuit hors antenne
c'est très bien et vous allez pouvoir le
poursuivre encore merci à tous les
théâtres d'être venu donc ce plateau
vous pouvez retrouver l'intégralité de
cette séquence sur notre site internet
dès demain matin on change de sujet
complètement à présent avant de passer à
la chronique de l'écho avec l'opération
pièces jaunes depuis le centre
hospitalier de versailles hier mercredi
bernadette chirac est venu lancer cette
opération c'est la présidente de la
fondation était accompagné des deux
parrains christian karembeu et clément
lefert le récent médaillé olympique
une venue très médiatique au centre
hospitalier de versailles à l'occasion
du lancement de l'opération pièces
jaunes opération qui permet d'apporter
un soutien financier à l'amélioration
des services pédiatriques dans les
hôpitaux de france par la dette chirac
en porte parole emblématique christian
42 et clément lefert en parent à la
fondation pedn a décidé cette année de
faire pas mal de projets sportifs dans
les hôpitaux pour aider à la réinsertion
de ces jeunes est aussi voilà c'est
important je me suis épanoui à travers
le sport et c'est important pour moi de
le partager
on peut pas laisser un enfant seul on le
sait doit de le guider on se doit d'être
à côté pour construire son avenir et en
l'occurrence ici pour essayer
d'améliorer son quotidien et
l'accompagné pourquoi pas dans sa
thérapie ici grâce aux pièces jaunes
plusieurs opérations de rénovation ont
été menées dans le service pédiatrique
la décoration de dix chambres pour les
nourrissons par exemple a été financé
une décoration avec de nouveaux meubles
et surtout des couleurs
ils vont pas dire c'est joli ici
c'est mais c'est dans le comportement
c'est beaucoup plus même pour les
parents d'arriver dans un endroit où il
ya de la lumière où il ya des motifs
agréable c'est pas du tout pareil qu'un
environnement où c'est tout blanc où
c'est plus stressant
donc ça ça aide en fait
dans la dynamique du service catherine
gaud league souhaiterait une aide
financière pour agrémenter les salles
pour adolescents ce qui ne laisse pas
bernadette chirac est différente
nous allons donner
une impulsion à la construction de
structures pour les adolescents vous
savez que nous avons reconstruit à paris
la maison de solenn est en face du val
de grâce où le var de port royal et qui
dont je suis très fier et nous avons
décidé de construire une maison de
solenn par département l'opération
pièces jaunes existe depuis 1990 elle se
déroule jusqu'au 16 février 850000
tirelire sont placés dans dix sept mille
bureaux de poste à travers la france